if you start making more money a lot of  people are curious about what they  should spend money on versus what they  should cut out i'm very very  conservative in terms of i've always  underspent my income by a very wide  margin because for me i'm very security  driven at the end of the day it has to  make sense for you because the one thing  that you have to protect above all else  is your headspace the first priority  things that you should be buying are  your time back somebody to get your  groceries somebody to cook your food  somebody to clean somebody to drive you  those are all things that you can buy  back and as long as you can make more  money in that time that you've bought  back it makes complete economic sense it  really depends on protecting you as the  number one